Speaker 1: This one is just an absolute beauty
that in a sense doesn't surprise me.
But it seems like it would be satire if you
didn't know any better.
During a recent segment on Fox News, a Fox
News anchor asked Republican Senator Mike
Braun from Indiana whether Joe Biden's economy
is essentially too good for Joe Biden to be
doing the things that he wants to do.
This is hilarious for several reasons which
we will get to now.
As many of you know, the stock market, which
Donald Trump told us would crash if Joe Biden
became president, has actually hit record
highs.
New unemployment claims are the lowest they've
been since the start of the pandemic, and
they're going lower every single week.
Joe Biden's vaccination plan is really popular.
Joe Biden's coronavirus stimulus package,
which passed in March, is very popular.
Joe Biden's proposed infrastructure package
is quite popular and things are just recovering
and sort of boring and increasingly looking
good.
It doesn't mean we've solved every problem
or even nearly that.
But in terms of comparing to what was going
on under Trump, things are looking pretty
good.
So here is a Fox News host saying the stock
market's doing great.
Unemployment is down.
Why is Joe Biden doing things?
Isn't it dangerous to be doing things when
the economy is booming?
It's almost like things are too good.
Take a look at this passing.
Speaker 2: Seeing a booming American economy,
whether it's the jobs market, the Dow, as
you see on your screen there, continues to
hit record highs.
You've got wages moving higher.
So why is it that this administration wants
to spend all this money when it seems things
are getting better?
Speaker 3: Well, that's a good question, because
the real consequences will be felt probably
post 2022.
And they're calculating all this expertly
in my mind, politically.
Speaker 1: Isn't that just something else?
All of this time, they've been denying that
things are actually going well.
And now all of a sudden with concern, they
say, oh, I don't know, the economy's booming,
the stock market's booming, the job market
is recovering.
And yet Joe Biden wants to do all this stuff.
I don't know.
That sounds like it could be dangerous to
do things when the economy is doing so well.
And Mike Braun, of course, throwing in.
Well, you know, the stuff Joe Biden wants
to do won't be good in the long term.
It might get him to twenty, twenty two in
good shape, but it's not going to be good
in the long term, which is a consideration
that they never make when they are pulling
their hair brained economic policy.
When a Republican is in power, they are so
desperate that it's actually hilarious.
Oh, no, the economy is booming and yet Joe
Biden still is doing things.
It's beyond parody.
They're essentially admitting that Biden is
so good at running the country, he shouldn't
even really be doing anything else.
And the fact that he's trying to should really
concern all of us.
The economy's doing dangerously well under
Joe Biden, and that could be a disaster.
Now, there's also a serious thing here, which
is, of course, a lot of the jobs that are
coming back for now are coming back part time.
They were full time, many of these jobs.
Why?
Well, we're in the middle of a pandemic recovery.
And as industries start to open, as different
sectors start to open, some of these jobs
will come back not provisionally, but on a
part time basis.
Many businesses operating with reduced hours.
The recovery has been disproportionately better.
For the very rich than it has for everybody
else, it's been the pandemic has been really
good for the ultra super rich and it has been
that kind of case shaped recovery that we've
talked about before.
Much of the stock market performance, which
has been stellar, goes to the very rich.
So there is a real question, which is even
though the economy is doing quite well for
wealthy people, what about everybody else?
And that's exactly what Joe Biden's spending
programs are trying to work on.
But we are at a point where even doing well
now is considered bad.
If you then continue trying to do more things,
as Joe Biden is trying to do, they have nothing
else to whine about.
We've gotten to the is the economy too good
part of the Joe Biden presidency?
And it's only like on month four, they were
just trying to give Trump credit for the economy
last week.
Now it's well, this is Biden's economy, but
it's almost like it's doing so well.
Something must be about to go wrong or it
must be terrible for Joe Biden to keep trying
to do stuff.
If you were to write a Saturday Night Live
script about how Fox News would cover the
circumstances now four months in three or
four months into Joe Biden's presidency, it
would be indistinguishable from is the economy
doing dangerously well?
And that's exactly what we're getting on FOX
News.
Let me know what you think they will go to
next in the manufactured crises.
Find me on Twitter
at David Pakman.
Hey, feel free if you're so inclined to grab
a membership on my website, join Pakman Dotcom.
It feels great, it's cheap, it's quick.
It's our primary source of funding on an ongoing
basis.
And you get the daily bonus show, award winning
as just one of many great membership benefits.
Join at Join Pakman Dotcom coupon code available.
Never mandatory better.
Twenty one saves you a bundle.